[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
let's talk about our democracy for a
minute
but let's do it in a way that makes the
snowflakes heads explode let me be clear
before this podcast begins we are loud
and do not give a [ __ ]
[Music]
this is the tony michaels podcast real
and raw political and social commentary
the freedom to oppress the rights of
other people is not liberty you [ __ ]
eating [ __ ] ah the smell of freedom of
speech this is the tony michaels podcast
and this is tony michaels
hey tony
[ __ ] them
[Music]
tuesday
[Music]
our favorite day
taco tuesday
the question of the day is will merrick
garland indict donald trump that is the
question of the day that is what
everyone wants to know that is what
everyone is freaking out about
on twitter
i'm glad you could join me this morning
because i am going to talk you know
you know i'm going to talk about this
hondo percento i'm going to talk about
merrick garland in the memo that was
released on rachel maddow's show on
msnbc last night which caused an
absolute freak out on social media on
twitterverse now led by don winslow
basically and his full on full-fledged
freak out
hmm
so we're going to talk about that but i
thank you for joining me here because i
know i know some of you are going to
totally disagree with me on this
but we're we're going to make it through
i promise i promise we'll make it
through
but again you have to remember
every every time
every time that
i say something
or that i'm trying to send a message or
trying to talk into the microphone or
give my opinion in general
it comes from a place
of pro-democracy
okay
i do not want to send a message out
anywhere that is not pro-democracy
that is authoritarian in nature i think
that is damaging to our republic
especially now in this existential time
where these fascists are trying to take
over our country where there are several
of them that would love to be the king
of the united states including donald
trump ron desantis and a few others
i think it is very irresponsible
and very anti-democracy to send out
authoritarian messages
i really do believe that
rather it's from the right or the left
either way we talked about this
yesterday both sizing [ __ ] people in the
chat were trying to defend tyt
of course i was knocking tyt in a in a
broad stroke in a broad manner
because they do they're they're they are
they are hurting our democracy
now if their claim is that they're
trying to hurt our democracy fine
whatever you know as long as they're
transparent about it
but here on the tony michaels podcast we
are pro-democracy i i believe in
democracy i believe in the institutions
of the democracy especially when other
people who believe in democracy are
running those institutions
and they prove that they are
pro-democracy that they are not
authoritarians
if you want to know the threat
to our country it's not just the far
right fascism isn't at the door and it
is a deadly type of authoritarianism
but if we on the left us liberals us
libtards if we start to believe that
authoritarian
is the way that our institutions should
be we are going to invite the fascist to
take over
that is what we will do
it again
democracy is very difficult
it is very difficult
it's not easy
that's why this idea that liberals are
weak and all this nonsense that's all
[ __ ] liberals are not weak
liberalism is the tough route to go
when you're talking about forming
governments when you're talking about
forming policy
it is tough it is a long hard fight it's
not easy authoritarianism is easy
i mean if you have an authoritarian you
can lock up your political enemies no
questions asked lock them up throw away
the key
boom
boom
you're done you don't need you don't
need you don't need to be tough
when you have authoritarianism you don't
need to be tough you don't have to be
but this memo from garland
is exactly the opposite
in this memo number one it's it's uh and
i think ben meizelos wrote this on
twitter it's boilerplate was the word he
used to describe it
it's typical [ __ ] from the department of
justice
to make sure that the united states
attorneys in these offices who are
bringing indictments who are who are
convening grand juries are not doing it
to to affect elections
this is what we accused them of doing
why would we want to do this
why would we want the biden
administration to use authoritarian rule
to
to force merrick garden the department
of justice to effect an election
doug jones put it one way last night on
a live on twitter doug jones the former
senator from alabama who is who is a
former department of justice official
said this
this is this is almost the same
as if we are if we're asking merrick
garland to to indict trump because of
the election
it's the same god damn thing as trump
pressuring zielinski in ukraine to have
an investigation on biden it is the same
aim
so stop with your anti-democracy
messaging don winslow that's right i'm
gonna call him out by name
full [ __ ] freak out by don winslow
and i'm a little disappointed in rachel
maddow in her reporting on this memo
i understand it's breaking news no one
else had seen it she wanted to break it
fine whatever
but the framing of it that merrick
garland isn't going to indict because of
this memo is really [ __ ] stupid
it's really [ __ ] stupid
look
john eastman
and jeffrey clark just had their cell
phones within the mass last month
han
they seized their cell phones
now that doesn't mean that they can
indict the next day
the doj has to do their due diligence if
you want them to convict these
[ __ ] with an uh with a real
indictment real charges a jury in a
court of law it takes a bit of time
it takes a really
really bit of time to make sure they
have a good case to make
the last thing we want is the department
of justice just to be slinging
indictments and lose every last one of
them
every last one of them
that would be worse than not they're not
trying to prosecute at all
so if you're a pro-democracy and you
believe in democracy act like it act
like it don winslow act like you believe
in democracy
merrick garland is to be trusted folks
there is nothing in merrick garland's
history
that anyone can point out don winslow or
otherwise that would suggest that
merrick garland is not going to do the
appropriate thing
which is to make sure that his united
states attorneys are bringing really
good cases
having having complete grand juries and
bringing
appropriate indictments
that's mayor garland's job he's the
attorney general
merrick garland doesn't bring charges
against trump that's not how it works
and i'd hate i'd hate to [ __ ] in
everyone's cereal
but listen
merrick garland is not
is not going to indict trump what i mean
by that is he is not the attorney that
does it
it is the united states attorney in the
district of dc or the district of
wherever he committed crimes that will
bring indictments merrick garland is the
attorney general yes he's going to be
briefed on those indictments because
they're high level indictments
but merrick garland personally isn't
going to be the one to decide to indict
trump it will come from grand juries
inside these districts again whether it
be new york whether it be d.c whether it
be georgia whether it be arizona florida
wherever he's committed crimes these
federal crimes or state crimes for that
matter
so think about it for a second why would
we as pro-democracy people want to
promote an authoritarian doj
why why do you want merrick garland to
be bilbar because that's
the most stupid [ __ ] case here that's
his that's his stupid [ __ ] case
is that
that merrick garland is bill barr that's
way he was saying it all night last
night on twitter he couldn't [ __ ]
stop over and over and over and over and
over and i'll show you the [ __ ]
tweets
he just can't [ __ ] quit
it's like a [ __ ] drug to him
because he wants to correct don wants to
be correct on this this idea that that
democracy will fail
and that merrick garland won't indict
which i don't even understand that if
don winslow is so [ __ ] pro-democracy
why is he pro
promoting an anti-democracy message
and don's on our side this is the same
stupid [ __ ] that we have to go through
that i was talking about yesterday
when they say don't don't [ __ ]
don't give donations to democrats
democrats are at fault democrats are the
reason why roe v wade is overturned
democrats are the reason blah blah blah
blah blah
both sides are not the same they're not
they're not the same
and yeah it's going to hurt the election
if you disappoint people in that [ __ ]
falsehood that the department of justice
is not going to work to indict anyone
who committed crime
you're going to hurt the election
that's what you're going to do so if
you're out there you're like hey we want
to win the midterms hey we want to win
the midterms
then be pro-democracy
use your ballot
as your weapon to win the midterms
because frankly the court of public
opinion is a thing that is going to
absolutely destroy trump
that's what will destroy trump trump
trump can run he can announce whatever
the [ __ ] he wants to do
but the court of public opinion is
already destroying him we're already
watching it in the polls
we're already seeing it affecting him in
his support
and trumpism as it were
fascism in a manga hat will move
and will shift towards someone like
desantis
trump is not the disease
trump is the symptom
so so
take a chill pill don winslow and just
just just figure out if you go back in
history and look at really high profile
cases at the doj that have to do with
things like i don't know obstructing
official proceedings
political crimes
financial crimes even it takes a long
time
it takes a long time
to bring those convictions i mean think
about this
the oath keepers trial the oath keepers
trial which they have a ton of evidence
built on the oath keepers we know that
from public just the information that we
have on the public jesus christ they
have oath keepers cooperating with the
doj
giving plea deals to turn on the oath
keepers leader stewart rhodes
and the trial isn't till december folks
and let me tell you something in
december they're going to push that
trial
that trial is going to happen probably
next year in 2023 sometime in the spring
or the summer is when it will start if
it starts at all if they don't even if
that if all those people don't play out
of that trial
this is how it works it's how it's
always worked don't let don winslow lie
to you and gaslight you to convince you
that the authoritarian way of merrick
garland
going and cuffing trump himself and
putting in him in prison is a good idea
it's not
we do not want that type of
authoritarianism in this country that
it's not what we want yes i understand
the threat of this of this election
but the actual criminal prosecution of
trump is not the thing that will make us
win this election the republicans are
handing you everything on a platter
everything jesus christ they're trying
for a national abortion ban at this
point not only not only are the
republicans responsible for overturning
roe v wade
as estates rights it's a states rights
issue now they want a national abortion
ban
there are women all around the country
that can't receive
very safe medical procedures
because of this
ted cruz ted cruz wants it to make it
gay marriage illegal
this is really easy stuff folks
this is really easy stuff
and frankly if trump wins it makes it
even worse on them because then then
he's on the ballot so let him run let
him run
what we have to do is politicize
everything and every every waking minute
every measure
and the january 6 select committee is
going to give us all that politicization
that we need
not just against trump but against
trumpism itself
because this thursday is gonna be a
bombshell it's gonna be a super show
i think we're gonna hear a lot of big
names in that testimony
we're supposed to hear from the deputy
uh
a white house press secretary
who left immediately after january 6 and
the national security council advisor
who left immediately after january after
they watched what donald trump did
or didn't do
we're supposed to see the tick tock
adam kinsinger is going to run the tick
tock from moment to moment in minute to
minute
i trust that he'll do a good job i'm not
exactly a kid singer fan but i think
kenzinger will do a good job at the tick
tock he even said sunday that yes you
are going to hear things that you have
not heard before
michelle there asked if we're coming on
thursday yes we are covering the hearing
on thursday
on youtube on the midas touch network
and we will cover that an hour before
we will have a panel during and a panel
after
it's probably going to be huge
bombshells so don't miss the coverage on
thursday
go over the link is in
the on the midas touch youtube channel
go over and set your reminder now
and then come back to the show or go
after
but it's on youtube you can find the
link
on our
twitter page
also minus touch twitter page but follow
us at tonymichaelspod you can follow me
at the tony michaels and follow my
co-host at i am gabe sanchez
and you will find that link
you can also subscribe to our youtube
channel please please please subscribe
here and download every single episode
we've had some trolls here lately give
us some bad reviews so do us a favor go
over to your favorite directory apple
google spotify wherever your favorite
directory is and give us give us a
five-star review
and write in there that you love us
or hate us you know whatever but help us
out over there on the reviews we've had
some trolls
you know you know how these trolls are
you see them on twitter
but it's very important to stay
in the lane of democracy here
and if we're not doing that we are doing
ourselves a disservice if we say we
believe in democracy
and we have to get on the same page as
democracy
we can't expect an authoritarian rule
we can't expect that if we expect that
we will invite these fascists to win
so get to it get to democracy
go
and participate and engage in your
democracy
it's time it's time that we work for
this midterm regardless of what happens
with the select committee regardless of
what happens with democracy are the the
indictments that merrick garland may or
may not bring merrick garland is not
going to indict anyone he's the attorney
general
the united states attorney and the
district offices are the ones who indict
and they use grand juries to do it
so trust in the the the actual
democracy that we have and i know i know
it's hard sometimes it's difficult
because it feels like we are at a at a
cliff
but merrick garland is not going to save
us here
the doj is not going to save us here it
is us who will save us
we are the people we are the government
that who is that's who will save us
and they wanted they wanted the
political trial to happen inside the
congress
you remember back when they the
democrats wanted a 911 style commission
that was a non-bias-style commission and
the republican said no
no we won a political trial
which forced the democrats
to convene a select committee in the
house
and then the republicans are mad oh
we're not going to participate in that
thinking that it would be
a great political stunt and it is
backfired on them
and the only reason why is because
they're ninca poop nazis folks they're
ninca poops
this idea that donald trump is
politically astute is [ __ ] stupid
it's really dumb
these fascists have crawled out
underneath their rocks to support him
but his support is waning here
it's only going to get worse as this
ticks on
as adam kensinger indicated that this on
sunday that this is not going to be the
last hearing on thursday it is not
they're not going to stop feeding us
the politics that we need to politicize
this
they're going to give us everything we
need because trump always does he always
does he never fails
never fails
so don't
don't discount your democracy don't
discount your institutions don't
discount
pro-democracy people and that memo the
memo
folks it is just standard [ __ ]
for merrick garland to make sure as
they're going to indict political
figures from the last administration
that there's not even a [ __ ] whiff
not even a hint
that it's to effect an election that is
all the warning is
is please
please
do not do not
make it look like we're trying to affect
elections because we don't want to do
that that is the last thing we want to
do in this country is to try to affect
elections
it's very dangerous stuff
and the reason why it's dangerous is
because
trust me
you give them just one inch
one inch and they'll take a mile we gave
them an inch in 2016 by not engaging in
our democracy
and letting 70 000 votes in one state
determine that donald trump be our
president
dangerous [ __ ] because we didn't engage
because we didn't believe in democracy
we didn't go vote
we thought it would all be okay
and here we are in this moment this is
the in the burning or bust movement this
is the bust part
this is it
them overturning roe v wade these these
election decisions that are gonna come
before this fascist bought and paid for
supreme court
that's the best part
it wasn't bernie losing this is the best
part
the same [ __ ] i was talking about
yesterday where tyt acts like democrats
are the same as republicans that's all
[ __ ]
that's all nonsense and [ __ ] drivel
stop listening to it and stop listening
to don winslow when he's talking about
how the doj isn't gonna do anything
about crime
it's nonsense it's [ __ ] drivel and
nonsense
i'm gonna show you some of it so you can
see it
and don's got a huge account and now you
know you send this to him send this to
him maybe he'll challenge me i would
love to have don on the show
i would love to have don on the show to
challenge him
it's time to stand up for our democracy
it's time to be pro-democracy full stop
there's no reason not to trust merrick
garland as the attorney general and
anyone anyone who anyone out there
wondering oh well there's probably
another person that could be a better
attorney general
well doug jones was one of them and he's
saying the same goddamn thing marigarlan
is saying in this memo
so pluck your head out of your ass and
realize that it's not
a good idea to promote authoritarianism
even if it helps you politically we do
not want the doj
bringing indictments to affect elections
we want them bringing indictments
because crimes have been committed
that's what we want
i have a special guest coming up after
the break the midas mighty
you know we simulcast from the minus
touch facebook page and we have a lot of
the midas mighty here we also have
sparklers a lot of hal hal sparks
his fans here
we welcome everyone who is pro-democracy
and you know what anyone who's
anti-democracy they could come listen
too
absolutely maybe we'll teach him a
[ __ ] thing or two
maybe we'll teach him a thing or two but
there is a huge
mightiest mighty star that is going to
be joining us and i think we're going to
try to do this once a week he joins us
on the panel
for the january 6 select hearings
and he's absolutely fantastic i love his
takes and i love his hat too i love his
hat i know everyone else likes his hat
and you know what i'm talking about i'm
talking about texas paul texas paul is
going to be joining us after the break
he's going to give us some news of how
he sees this race with beto and abbott
going down i believe uh so he's going to
give us a little bit of a a rundown on
that
so stick around after the break we will
have texas paul with us
to break down to break down texas on
tuesday
stick around don't go anywhere we'll be
right back right after these
messages be right back
mark
60 seconds this is the tony michaels
podcast
[Music]
are you numb and alone after storming
the capital have you been left out in
the cold after stealing nancy pelosi's
mail do you feel exposed to a government
that doesn't share your patriotic values
if any of these describe you then you're
in luck hi i'm paul gosar and thanks to
my new product pardon blanket i've got
you covered pardon blanket specifically
works to make you feel safe and cozy
after your involvement on january 6th
and if you're one of the other members
of congress who also helped with the
attempted coup pardon blanket will
protect you too hard and blanket is made
of a sort of soft fleece and a layer of
sheep's wool and they're a hundred
percent made in the usa
don't delay and get your pardon blanket
today for just 99.99
actual parting's not guaranteed
jumping back into it this is the tony
michaels podcast
welcome welcome welcome back to the show
thanks for joining us here on the tony
michaels podcast every single weekday
monday through friday noon eastern 11
central nine pacific right here on
youtube twitter and twitch
and simo casting from the midas touch
facebook page
thursday's gonna be a banger folks
it's gonna be a [ __ ] banger
we're gonna find out the tick tock of
what the former guy the cheeto dust
monster did and really what he didn't do
to to trying to stop his mob that he
incited to go kill the vice president of
the united states um i i think i
actually think that that's going to be
what we're going to hear on thursday it
the the likelihood is that the thing
that's going to surprise you the most is
the evidence that is actually going to
be put in front of the american people
of how donald trump didn't give a to two
[ __ ] shits not two of them
if if the vice president was killed
frankly he might have even encouraged it
inside the white house i think that is
what we're gonna find out i know mark
short which is uh mike pence's former
chief of staff has given deposition i
don't know if we'll see
from their perspective inside the garage
what what the secret service were saying
what the vice president was saying what
they knew
was happening at the white house how
they knew it was happening
we know we know that that was the threat
to the vice president of the united
states um and i think thursday we're
going to see some of that evidence
and we know this is happening i mean
this has been kind of the theme here is
that
we know we know the [ __ ] news about
january 6. we know this stuff we've seen
the reporting it's it's been a while and
there's been a lot of reporting on
january 6. it's just now the january 6
select committee can put it in a way
that feeds the evidence to the american
people as opposed to a new york times
article that is cited by you know
confidential sources this is not
confidential sources these are people
that are sitting right next to donald
trump right next right next to mike
pence and these aren't democrats these
are [ __ ] republicans every last
[ __ ] one of them are republicans who
are testifying who are being deposed who
are giving the evidence it's not
democrats
jesus christ on thursday it's going to
be republican
doing the tick tock with other
republicans sitting there as witnesses
the deputy press secretary for donald
trump his national security council
these aren't [ __ ] libtards
these are these are trump lodites
and they watched him try to commit a
coup and their democracy is a little
more important
to them than the cheeto dust mobster
that's why they're going to testify
that's why we're going to see the tick
tock
and on thursday we're going to have a
very important panel guest join us which
he's joined us
several times i think every single time
i think he's been there every single
hearing
and i think he's there almost every
single panel that we have before
during the break and after
he's a huge contributor to the midas
touch network though he's a midas mighty
favorite he's one of my favorites just
because of the way that he frames things
up i'm kind of a hillbilly you know i'm
from the middle part of the country he's
he's from texas
but you know we kind of speak the same
language every once in a while
so i want to welcome i want to welcome
for the first time to the show texas
paul texas paul how are you man i'm
wonderful tony i'm wonderful hey i'm
glad to have you here today i think we
should do this every tuesday where you
give us a report because there's a lot
of stuff going on in your state of texas
that has to do with our democracy and i
think maybe we should do this every
tuesday
absolutely absolutely let's do it so
what do you got for me today because i
know you wanted that you had a subject
you wanted to talk about what do you got
for me today here well i got a couple of
things for you today but uh we're going
to talk about meadow and and abbott
because we've got some great news on
that front uh it's just amazing but
there's something real quick i wanted to
give you a big thanks how's my audio by
the way your your audio is doing great
no is that echo that i normally have in
this barn gun uh well it's it's still a
little bit of echo we'll have to work on
that we have to work on that
this is for you i'll make it quick i
promise yeah go ahead
you know i'm tearing the office apart
preparing
you know taking all the soundproofing
advice and everything that you gave me
oh i see
yeah i remember
this this is for you buddy i straight up
hillbilly this mic
oh that's perfect that's beautiful
it's beautiful
that's great here you know i've got the
hardwood floors in here and it's just
echoes everywhere and i just i did what
i wanted you to see that my friend yeah
oh it's perfect
i was thinking about you buddy that's
perfect why i want to bring in my
co-host and executive producer gabe
sanchez uh gabe has joined us for the
hearings as well i know he i know i know
he's a big texas ball fan texas has got
a report from uh texas for us gabe about
beto and the abbott campaign what do you
got what do you got for us paul
oh man i tell you dude fantastic
fantastic news
beto just blew the roof off
in fundraising you folks out there i
love you i swear to god i love you to
death i swear to god
i wish i could just hug and kiss every
one of you because
you have been putting your money where
your mouth is you've been
doing what's necessary volunteering
taking care of business and it shows it
shows better just set a record for the
state of texas for fundraising for the
gubernatorial race and that's a big deal
we throw a lot we throw more money at
the gubernatorial race than we do we do
high school football and that's saying
something you know what i mean
but anyways twenty seven point six
million bucks
he just pulled in
eventually from the nice that's great so
so he's beating abbott in the in the
arena of raising money
yeah
by two and a half million dollars well
you know i think i think that goes back
to this new brand that the democrat
party should really adopt um
there's there's paul with his coke zero
uh we were giving him a little bit of
[ __ ] yesterday in the chat um drinking
coke zero but um and so maybe i'll let
him go after gabriel but you know i i
the point i was trying to make about the
new branding because we we
we notice um tim ryan having a certain
type of branding uh fetterman has uh
leaned into this type of branding for
the democratic party which i actually
think that this type of branding will
work anywhere and everywhere it doesn't
matter how liberal the place uh i think
i think people out there are ready for
the democrats to fight hard take the
gloves off and really kick some ass and
i think that's what betto's doing down
there in texas he's not leaving any
stone unturned um and and it comes from
a very authentic place right like when
he showed up the other day i watched a
video of beto um showing up at a march
at uvalde um where where these parents
in these town they're [ __ ] pissed
down there they are absolutely pissed
that 400 uh law enforcement officers
showed up at that school
and let that rampage continue they're
[ __ ] pissed and they want answers
right um and and beto
went down there now what
when when politicians normally do this
stuff like greg abbott appears to be a
political stunt but when beto did it it
was it came from a very authentic place
kind of like the branding that's
happening with tim ryan and fetterman um
so tell us about that what what do you
see that beto is doing that makes it so
authentic because i watch him play with
billy nelson and things and but what
what is it that makes that campaign
stand out that people are giving money
to beto to make sure that their state is
bettered
you can't fake it you can't fake it he's
just a good man he is he's a good decent
human being he feels it i mean he really
does there's no [ __ ] about it i mean
abbott's a [ __ ] bag he ran to collect
some cash at a dinner before he went
down to meet with people in new valley
um
you can't fake it i mean that's why
that's why i have it's tanking so bad um
when beto started this
he was 15 points down and the more
people see him the more people talk to
him he's one of us
he will tell you to go [ __ ] yourself he
has actually told somebody that before
on camera um
i i already like him just that alone
that alone makes me like him
[Laughter]
he is just genuine like that he is and
it shows the polling uh he was down by
15 points when this started he's closed
the gap to five
wow but more important than that the
enthusiasm gap
is huge
the right track wrong track numbers
59 of texas voters
registered voters think that we're on
the wrong track and the republicans are
making a huge mistake here a huge
mistake here they're really looking at
this race like every other race and it's
not
there's just been a sea change here in
texas people are sick of it i mean
between the power grid they see nothing
getting done you got the port down
galveston that's falling apart it's one
of the largest ports in the country man
the roads leading down there are trash
they're
they're
pothole
mess the the piers are
broken concrete it's it's sad to look at
it really is
um i mean everything in this state and
when when
republicans took office the governorship
in 94 with with uh bus jr
he was handed a pristine state we had
taken oil money
and built the infrastructure that was
just the envy of the world i mean the
whole world we were so proud of i
remember being a young man in the
workforce
so proud of that state highways were the
best there were we had the most modern
power grid we had in
bush came in republicans took over a few
years later in the legislature and
they've done nothing since and people
see it and they're tired of this culture
war [ __ ] we had we had a woman
the other day and
just it tears me up
um
[Music]
she had to carry a fetus a dead fetus
around
in her body for two weeks
right
okay
i saw that i saw that before yeah the
story is incredibly devastating i mean
and then he's pulling another thing you
remember i got all over him about that
[ __ ] he was pulling at the border with
the trucks
yeah
okay
he's pulling two more two more operation
lone star down here at the border
they're just lying about arrests they're
uh taking people that are coming across
the border they this is going to be huge
this was going to be huge
they finally gave up some body cam
footage because immigrants and and
asylum seekers were were being charged
with trespassing and they were
throwing them in jail for six months
um
what they found out is that the
state police officers were parking on
private property they would arrest
people on public property then they
would march them to the car
and when they got to the car
they would cite them for trespassing
on private property
because they were arresting well you
know
that seems to blow up all over the world
that's illegal
right yeah why i know i know i know a
big issue i know a big issue in texas
right now is the law enforcement and
gabe has done some reporting on uh what
was that
with the um several several episodes
about you've evolved
there will be another one uh after the
after the jan six hearing there will be
another one that will be covering the
whole timeline and the incompetency and
just the lack of
of you know
of
doing doing their job right they had
nearly 400 uh
law enforcement agents or officers that
were trained multiple times hours on end
even uh oredondo had training like none
of these guys despite having all their
training you know had the
i guess you know courage bravery
whatever you want to call it uh
willingness to go in and actually you
know save those children and it is
devastating but like you know texas paul
you know hits a nail on the head here
like
republicans have done a terrible job i
mean you know just
just mentioning the story of the woman
who had to carry that fetus for enact
you know to bur to to term
you know watching that uh that coverage
on it and her having to say
i think the thing that hurt me the most
was
her explaining how the doctor had to
tell her again that she had lost her
child or three times right you know and
be like all right we're going to go with
the ultrasound and she's like corporate
ultrasounds before you give her a dmc
right right exactly and it's important
you know they're like well in abortions
abortion and it's like it's not black
and white it's not this or that like you
you have to understand that there are
there are situations like this or an
ectopic uh
a pregnancy where it's like it it
it will impact the life of the mother
you know and texas and other republicans
are like
well it is what it is and that's the
unfortunate reality we live in and i
think
the other thing too you started
mentioning all these things that are
like wrong with texas and how we can
improve them especially under leadership
of of beto
is the uh the mothers against abbott
right like they had that campaign the
video that came out yesterday and i
thought it was very well done women of
all you know a medley of backgrounds and
living situations but all standing up
for the same goal the same objective
which is to remove abbott from office
because he has ruined all of these lives
and doesn't have
you know the best interest or well-being
for those who are in texas such as
yourself or any sort of other woman or
person of color or anyone who's a who is
a marginalized group that isn't
represented like these are these are
people that need better representation
and abbott is just someone who doesn't
really care and we saw that you know
baldi
with everything
and you know like like you brought up
maga
mothers against greg abbott they
co-opted the maga title
um
this is what's important about that
group i mean other than
their i mean their obvious importance
is that that group is nonpartisan
there are republican women in that group
there are independents in that group
there are democrats in that group that
group is specifically non-partisan they
don't care what you are all they want is
change in the way that texas does
business
um
but you know
talking about greg abbott and the
republicans inability to to govern it's
always stunts you remember the bus stunt
where he sent that bus full of
immigrants to fox news yeah i think he's
still doing it he's still sending them
to dc of course there's some groups
there's some groups in dc that are that
are helping those folks as they get
there but they know they're coming um
because he's he's doing this stunt and
ted cruz is playing into the stunt too
it's all part of a i mean
the most terrible thing about that
situation is the fact of either not
telling them where they're going or
telling them that they're going
somewhere and then going to a completely
different area right and just dropping
them off they're just dropping them off
on a goddamn side instead of being like
hey look you came over we're going to
send you back to mexico or we're going
to send you you know to wherever you
came from you know deport you they say
no
we're going to make it worse for you you
don't know the area you don't speak the
language we're going to send you
somewhere that is completely unknown you
have no bearing in mind and that's the
welcoming gift that you have at you know
to america which is like go [ __ ]
yourself and that is
right period these are human beings that
they're just throwing could you imagine
somebody gave if i just took you to
germany and you know
through you in in in berlin
dropped you off
you know you had
limited amount of money
you didn't speak the language clearly
you i mean just just dropped you off
right i mean no phone no way to
communicate yeah these are from
hardy-ass people but this is the good
news on this is it's backfired
big
well it doesn't everything they do
though texas paul and everything that
they do is it's it's overstepping i mean
i mean they were like let's overturn roe
v wade and everything will be great they
overturn roe v wade and here they are
all week long on the house floor we need
a national ban on abortion [ __ ] states
rights we need a national ban like i
thought it was about states rights not
about a national ban but here we are
today and they're going to come after
contraception they're going to come
after your right to actually have
the sex that you want and who you're
going to love i mean ted cruz your
senator your state even said it the
other day he doesn't want he doesn't
want gay marriage he thinks that that
should be overturned and and they're
going to come after interracial marriage
i mean it's going to continue
what's that ted has a gay child
and he's coming out publicly against
yeah
he has a gay child and he's coming up
they don't give a [ __ ] about people what
i was going to tell you though is some
good news on the on on yeah that that
that scam that abbott's pulling now is
that for years charities have been
trying to get the state to kick in to
ship people to other cities to give them
support to move to other cities in dc
they said okay we need some help with
this because
we weren't they didn't coordinate with
us these folks are just showing up we
need help
they're not complaining that they're
there they're glad to have the workforce
so catholic charities has stepped up
and helped the city of bc
so the people that are getting the bus
ride the asylum seekers are like well
thank you you put us in the center your
government and made our
chances of getting asylum increase by 90
percent judges here in texas do not
approve asylum for asylum seekers they
have like a 93 rejection rate judges in
dc have a 90 percent approval rating for
people seeking assignments right
they they have they have hearts and
compassion right right yeah like you put
us front and center in of the issue with
all the lawmakers the parishioners in bc
thank you and dc's like wow we had a
labor shortage thank you
well i mean i i made this argument here
on this show several times paul that
that this is one of the issues that we
have with the labor force is that for so
many years the trump administration
didn't want migrants coming here and to
seek to seek labor to seek jobs to seek
income to seek labor and they didn't
want it and and then we had the pandemic
and we have other causes
but everyone's one running around going
why isn't there any help anywhere well
number one they're not paying where the
[ __ ] at these places and people are able
to move their labor because there's
demand you're able to demand more when
you trade because i you know i think
this is one thing that um i think you're
trying to get at here is that that yes
these communities whether it's dc or
these other cities or some of these
outlying communities need the labor they
actually need it
to function for their economy to
function fully because we are missing
out on a ton of demand here in our
economy because we don't have the labor
force to to fill some of these gaps and
i think that's very important to
understand that migrants in our country
one of the the biggest gifts they give
to our economy one of the biggest
contributions that they give to our
economy is their hard work this idea
that migrants are [ __ ] lazy is
absolutely 100 totally delusional has
always been delusional migrants are some
of the hardest working [ __ ] people
that you will find because they come
here knowing that they're not going to
get the best job right away that they're
going to have to trade their labor for a
lesser amount and they're going to have
to work up the chain to find a better
job they understand that and they're
some of the hardest working people on
earth well it's just it's just like you
know all as always it's projection right
right it is the party's own insecurities
and projection on to another group that
don't have the same rights or access to
benefits that you know i as a white
person might have or whatever it is
right like you look at that and that's
the unfortunate reality we live in where
it's yes you have people coming over the
border you know these these migrants who
are the hardest working who have to
prove themselves right because they're
already a disadvantage like you said and
then you have these republicans they're
like oh you're you know and then they
come up with some random [ __ ] to
make some reason why they shouldn't be
there that's racist they come up with a
racist reason just say it
crush their heads man it's just and this
is the difference between republicans
and democrats okay if if this was better
okay if this was better
better would coordinate with
other cities
other states
and this would be a good thing this
would be a win for
think about it there he is solving so
many problems with this
but no it's a failure it's a complete
blow up on him why
because they wanted to hurt people
they wanted to hurt people they wanted
to cause problems and the fact i mean
think about that difference between
republicans and democrats democrats this
is a win we're doing a good thing for
everybody involved right republican oh
this didn't work we didn't hurt enough
people right we didn't all our people
didn't get enough jollies off of this
because these people aren't hurt bad
enough and people are helping them oh
hell
well
that's the republican way paul that's a
republican way i mean texas texas has
the ability to what i will call
a pipeline to success or a pathway to
success like you could you know not only
oil coming out of you know texas but
it's the ability to have a pipeline
to send help aid labor whatever and
texas could be could could totally
rebrand itself as a place where if you
want to come to this country come
through texas it could be almost the new
ellis island right you come through
texas and you're now saying all right
great we need someone in montana or
wyoming or indiana or new york or
whatever it might be
but
allowing those abilities or those
opportunities to come could be a huge
way of attracting people into texas
gabe i think you just gave texas paul a
great a great setup for a great video
that you can find on the midas touch
network um uh paul
uh you know maybe you and gabe can
collaborate on a video or something that
that sounds like a great
texas the new ellis island maybe there's
a commercial maybe there's a fancy green
screen in there somewhere i don't know
i'm just saying this sounds like a great
video one thing i want to touch on paul
before we go because i'm gonna have to
go to a break and then we're gonna get
to the [ __ ] list roundup so stick around
uh and watch the show after that because
we're gonna we got a lot of video to get
through paul um but i wanna ask you
about thursday's hearing because i know
you're gonna you're gonna come join the
panel um real quickly within a few
minutes what do you expect to see out of
the hearing tell the audience what texas
paul wants to see from this hearing um
so that way the audience knows what to
expect from your commentary on thursday
well i know what i'm going to see from
the hearing but i also know they're
going to surpass my expectations because
they have at every hearing i you know i
expect i know what i'm going to see
going in you know the the two witnesses
that they have are people that resigned
on january 6 after watching this
[ __ ] going on in the white house
they just it just these were trumpers
these were these were republicans that
wanted to be at the core of the trump
white house and they were sickened by
what they saw so you know you know you
and i are not prepared for what we're
about to see
on thursday this is going to be
disgusting what we see i mean if it was
enough to make these two sycophants who
wanted to be there
just walk up and drop a resignation
letter on the desk you know damn well
that we're gonna hear about some
behavior out of trump that's just gonna
be jaw-dropping it yeah i think it's
going to be vile i i appreciate you
joining us thanks for giving us the
update on that race come back next
tuesday i'll see you on thursday but
come back next tuesday
i talked to laura we're adopting you you
have no choice okay oh well there you go
there you go and maybe maybe i'm just
floating this maybe you two should work
out that ellis island thing there's got
to be an idea there i think that's a
great idea there's something there
there's something there and paul thanks
for joining us in the chat i know the
audience loves to have you in the chat
your your big midas mighty favorite
thanks for joining us in the chat
yeah well i i love i love not just
having you on but having you as an
audience member as well and i appreciate
all your support and i i love having you
on the panel and again we'll try to have
you back every tuesday maybe i don't
know what we'll call it texas uh
tuesdays from texas or texas texas
tuesdays i don't know we'll cover them
do something good we'll get a little
traffic that's right maybe we're getting
it we get gabe to do a graphic or
something
texas paul on tuesday i don't know but
if we can make it a thing everyone can
come and watch texas paul give us texas
news on tuesdays thank you thank you
texas paul uh everyone stick around we
will be right back right after this
break
what the [ __ ] is wrong with you people
it's a rhetorical question at best
we'll be right back on the tony michaels
podcast
[Music]
fellow patriots what would you do if
there was a trump supporter right in
front of you crying in pain because they
have to live under communist tyranny
we know what you would do you'd reach
out and give that true american a hand
now here's your chance for only 50 a day
you can help us help those true
americans recover from biden's socialist
reign of terror these are those trump
supporters and this is that moment
send your donation via venmo to the real
president donald j trump
it's only 50 a day i'm recurring and it
means you'll get these trump supporters
the critical help they so desperately
need to survive under this false regime
please donate now because those trump
supporters you just saw
can't wait another moment
[ __ ] em
[Music]
we're back to the tony michaels podcast
welcome welcome welcome back to the show
texas paul tuesday's texas tuesdays
[Music]
i don't know what we'll call it
everyone's shopping gabe they're
shopping the uh
the new name down here
we float one thing they love texas ball
they love having one i'm honestly i'm
i'm just still
reeling in the fact that i have a new
family yeah you know that's good i
you should go visit your family in texas
i should you know i should make i'm
cheering up over here man you know
every uh some people see here we get we
got texas texas tuesday a terrible texas
tuesday it ain't going to be terrible
forever
get out there and get out there and work
and and won't be terrible forever
let's see what what else do we have here
a taco t taco tuesday with texas paul
gabe we love taco tuesday
we love talking we love talking tacos on
taco tuesday me and gabe are both fans
of tacos now of course he's he's a
little more of a connoisseur about tacos
than i am but i love tacos i love tacos
they're great it's great there's so much
good that comes out of them almost
almost as good as some of the texas paul
commentary here's another one texas two
step two texas paul two-step tuesday
there's that that's that may be that may
be a little bit of a tongue twister for
for me but you know i think that's a
good one uh texas paul tuesday so
there's a lot of good uh margie says
tacos in texas tuesdays
so you know i don't know i don't know
maybe maybe we can come up with a name
for this i i like having paul on um he's
been great for the hearings uh great
commentary like i said he speaks my
language i think he speaks a lot of
people's language out there that's why
he's such a midas mighty favorite and
speaking of that make sure you go after
the show to the midas
minus touch network youtube page
make sure to click the link
there for thursday's hearing it's day
eight it's at the very top and and make
sure to set a reminder and that that
hearing the gavel will go down at eight
eastern in the evening it's a prime time
hearing but we will start our coverage
with texas paul he'll join us at the
panel at seven o'clock eastern so make
sure to set your set your reminders
sorry chris chris ends said give us a
wave so i'm giving this game away there
you go with my my little with your trump
hand with my trump hands yeah
yeah you're trumpians oh my god
if you if you guys noticed in the last
what was that i thought i thought it
looked like you were like playing with
your nipples with the trumpet oh yeah no
it's just because yeah but that's what
it looked like to me that's what i are
you know yeah you need they need longer
sticks well longer sticks but i feel
like they need longer arms so it can
look like my arms oh okay i see because
i see just like this you know well maybe
you should fashion something come on man
aren't you the prop guy listen there was
there was there was a picture going
around the internet of someone's nipples
here was it yeah
oh
you didn't see this no i know you saw it
i know you saw it you made you made a
great and i actually post on youtube oh
well here's the thing how could anyone
miss it it was like uh it was like you
know you could see it from a long ways
away it was like whoa look at that
supernova like that it was like crazy
blinding almost the same shade of white
as the yacht what in the actual [ __ ] was
that
how the [ __ ] do you get that white
uh
is he bleaching i mean is he bleaching
i've heard a lot of bleaching jokes over
the last uh 12 hours from people online
i've seen you know you sent me one yeah
that seems to be more or less the
the theme of the bleaching but yeah i
mean like even i had a plan to post a
photo of mark zuckerberg with when he
had the
his whoopi goldberg uh or not what we go
um
um mrs doubtfire i don't know why i said
that but uh robin williams mrs doubtfire
when he had the whipped cream on his
face he's like hello
mark zuckerberg i didn't i didn't see
that i didn't mark zuckerberg took a
photo a few years back and he was uh
surfing in hawaii and he has a [ __ ] ton
of sunscreen i will pull it up
because yeah yeah give me give me the
link cause we're gonna i'm we're gonna
go
because apparently apparently
um
the the color
of elon musk won color of the year
um for panda yeah that's what i saw so
i'm gonna go show everyone and i posted
that on youtube that he won color of the
year so at least he got an award
somewhere now i also said
you know based on how we look because i
think this is [ __ ] hilarious because
all these [ __ ] elon sims out there
like oh he's the greatest thing ever
he's a god he's a king and and they make
fun of everyone else you know for their
body type or whatever and here's this
[ __ ] fat slob on a yacht all right
this is the link to the photo of mark
zuckerberg
if anyone had not seen this you're
welcome but also i'm sorry and if you
have seen it
welcome back is this going to get us
banned no no oh okay okay get us banned
oh okay i didn't know what exactly i
don't know what exactly what it is oh my
god
oh jesus
you want to zoom in on that bad boy when
you come in let me let me oh look at
this guy this is uh mark zuckerberg
protecting that billion dollar face of
his because i don't the money maker i
don't know what's worse is this guy
thinking he's cool because this is the
same is this the same kind of surfboard
thing that he's riding with the american
flag yeah i believe so it's got the
motor and it rides on it propels itself
on the waves right uh yeah and yeah i
believe it to be the same one
uh that he was using i think that might
be even in control on his hand but yeah
it's it's the same
same board he had when he was doing his
american flag
[ __ ] dystopian type of
but this one he's protecting his
precious face right exactly
what what is that that i don't know man
it is something else so that's what i
said it looks like
uh mrs doubtfire
oh yeah yeah yeah
because because in the scene robin
williams character right is trying to
fool
the public because he doesn't have his
right because right he doesn't have he
doesn't look like mrs doubtfire he looks
like
the his character with the wig on so he
has to put his face in so you can't see
right the face and i'm hoping that
everyone understands the reference but
if not
here oh you got a link for it yeah yeah
yeah of course gabe has here's the
reference for anyone who doesn't know
and if you haven't seen the movie please
go see the movie it's very good
well you're talking about mrs down fire
yeah yeah yeah yeah
oh yeah well absolutely who doesn't like
um so this is you know
zuck zuck mark zuckerberg pulling a mrs
doubtfire oh my god
you think it would you think it
what do you think the flavor is on on
zuckerberg's face we know this is
probably like whipped icing on on robin
i don't know what do you think agility
if i had to guess like with a very light
light like uh it's not real sugar but
it's like um
man-made you know it's like it's not
it's the same type of sugar you might
find like a diet coke or a diet dr
pepper or something right now right
that is what i believe
is the you know it's like t it tastes
like that type of fake sugar
um
but yeah that is uh you know him pulling
to mark zuckerberg but holy [ __ ] man the
amount
of whiteness he's almost he
even casper the ghost was like yo dude
he's up on the eve on the white on the
whitey thing again
well let's hear let's do this because i
got a lot of video and i want to look at
that i want to look at the uh
the color of the year award that he won
um so let's do this let's go
let's go round up all the tweety tweets
in the trendy trend start the countdown
for the [ __ ] list roundup right now
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Applause]
[Music]
the [ __ ] list
welcome welcome welcome back to the tony
michaels podcast we've recent part of
the show where we round up all the
tweety tweets and the trinity trends we
got a lot of video to round up today um
gabe there's a lot of news a lot of
people freaking out i i talked about in
the first 30 minutes uh people are
losing their [ __ ] ever loving minds
over this merit garland memo i think
they're misunderstanding and
misinterpreting it
obviously rachel did some reporting on
it i'm kind of disappointing in the
reporting she did but you know and
obviously she wanted to get that and she
wanted to get that memo out there into
the public she wanted them to see it
which i don't think well
there
could you know some people are there's
some whispers that the reason that
people started freaking out and certain
individuals started freaking out so
extremely and causing everyone else to
freak out was due to adam schiff in his
appearance on the show
uh talking about those documents so i
don't know
well i mean again i i think i think the
freak out is a little overdone and the
reason why it's overdone is because it
only perpetuates this authoritarian
stuff right um which if you're really
paying attention to what is happening
with the doj and january 6
you'll know that people are being
indicted
um here's a great
a great picture from inside the
courtroom
of steve bannon's uh court hearing on
the contempt charge
um i have it i have it here it's
exclusive here wow that is yeah that's a
courtroom's artist's sketches
yeah well i mean you know they didn't
have a camera in there so they yeah they
do a sketch
i have i just want to point out that i
am i've always been i always want to
know how this process goes down
like
how
someone who is sketching this like what
you know are they just
quickly getting the outlines like how i
don't know i'm fascinated by this
process and i want to i want to be in
the courtroom in a courtroom at some
time and i want to watch the sketch
artist just go to town i'm sure i can
find tick tock on it but
i've always been fascinated by like how
quickly they're like got the image in my
head and i got the outline boom got you
know and then from there it's there well
you know um
they really captured
how filthy steve bannon
you know is in this sketch i mean it's
it's very accurate
um
obviously this is this is this is pair
seth it's it's parody it's name it's not
it's not real um
our friend um uh pete peely texas uh
did this
did this sketch
um and it's a great it's a great thing
he actually got pig pen trending uh yeah
i saw the yes yeah cause a lot of people
a lot of people were kind of and i think
it was humorous they were a little upset
that he then he you know here's here's
the original
why would people get upset at paul he
does the same stuff that i do he's the
same stuff as other like as as politiks
like all of these people
we are here to inject some humor and
make you know bring things kind of a
light-hearted approach right you know we
don't have to hurt pen
it's not it's not the hurt pig pen right
yeah yeah did people find it insulting
that they're like oh dude well i mean i
think some people were making jokes that
you know whatever it's a joke and it's
you know in the moment it's funny and
it's like great okay cool we move on the
next thing that will be funny that comes
out of this is the fact that he
continues to say hey judge i want to
move this or i want to do this and the
judge is like no [ __ ] that steve bannon
you're going to do this trial we've got
our jurors we've selected them right
you're going to have to go through with
this court case and not only that
they're taking phones from jeffrey clark
john eastman yeah um there's there's
more charges being brought i mean the
other thing is each time that these
events happen where somebody like
eastman or clark go on to tucker carlson
or fox news and say i was a victim they
came in and did this then the video was
released
of them getting said devices or the
search warrant happening and you've got
clark who for whatever reason answers
the door with no pants on and then once
he goes outside he just stands there in
complete shame good
but also like i said in the latest what
was that it's like if you don't want
that to happen one put a pair of pants
on or two don't try to throw a coup
right right like well you know the other
gets the other one was john eastman when
he was he was like oh you didn't show me
the warrant first you can't like some
stupid thing like no it's a lawful
you're a you're a you're a lawyer like
right he's such a [ __ ] idiot it's not
even how it works like the the judges
issued a warrant and they're serving the
warrant they don't have to show it to
you first before they detain you they
are being spiritual right now right like
they could take it off your body without
having you to you know put up your arms
right willingly they could say
no [ __ ] you and i'll take it i just want
to point out in the video here that you
didn't show me this piece of paper
that's an official court document before
you started to detain me which is really
stupid but i i want to point out to
everyone here um texas ball has pants on
doesn't throw coos uh well you know that
good for you texas paul um i'm glad you
wore pants on the show today you
wouldn't actually have to i mean yeah
you're on the show
sometimes i don't you know i don't i
don't always wear pants um anyways uh
back to you some real stuff here this is
this is the person that they claim is
not going to indict now don winslow is
and i'm going to call him out by name i
don't give a [ __ ] don winslow is one of
the ones who stokes a lot of this fear
online right now i mean he continues
because he got a really big following
and last night he was in full [ __ ]
freakout mode gabe i'm gonna show you
some of this stuff full [ __ ] i mean
i sent you that gift which was chicken
little right and like you know anything
he's following the sketch guy's falling
like that is the alarmist kind of there
are certain things that we should be
alarmist about you know right but like i
don't know a a former president
overthrowing a government and we're
going to hear about that right this week
and listen to what merrick garland says
here about the hearing that we're gonna
hear
on thursday listen to what he's down
this is back before the hearing started
but listen to what he says about the
hearings i am uh watching and i will be
watching all the hearings although i may
not be able to watch all of it live but
i'll be sure that i'll be watching all
of it and i can assure you that the
january 6 prosecutors are watching all
the hearings as well there's nothing
that's coming in the way of our
investigation we are
proceeding with full urgency with
respect
as i've said many times before um
to hold
all perpetrators who are criminally
responsible for january 6 accountable
regardless of their uh level their
position and regardless of whether they
were present
i want i want to put everyone's mind at
ease here because here's the words that
you need to hear from mayor garland
right here he says in the way of our
investigation we are proceeding with
full urgency and then he follows up with
respect that's what the letter was
yeah it's the respect they have to
respect democracy they cannot and will
not and should not
prosecute someone because an election is
coming that is not they should not
prosecute someone to effect elections we
are we are as we approach the 2022
midterms right this is you know we are
not we are not even discussing 2024
right now this is in right in
preparation for the 2022 midterms it's
like hey this is what our role is as the
doj this is what we can and can't do and
if we will pursue it then we will do it
this way the other thing that people
need to realize that they have just
completely had just a memory loss on is
that in march the doj hired i think over
130 new investigator slash prosecutors
to add on to their january 6
investigation well and the other news
that we have just in the last few weeks
from the hearings is the doj and and the
january 6
select committee are cooperating with
each other we see that with some of this
testimony where they would kind of go
one before the other i mean that's why
that's why we the hearings there were
some exactly there was some juggling
that had to happen because they were
making moves in real time
and well the other evidence that we see
is that the doj has requested that all
the testimony all the depositions and
all the scripts be handed over and the
january 6 select committee is working in
that form and fashion to get them there
it really is [ __ ] boneheaded stuff
well the other thing too that's really
important for people to remember is the
fact that all of this stuff that the
january 6 committee has been
diligent about they have gone over the
details scrape through all of the
depositions look through the all the
things had the video ready
everything is categorized everything is
ready to go they know who is talking
what they were talking about you know
they i would wouldn't be surprised if
they had matrix tables to see how one
person's deposition cross cross
reference another person's deposition
about an exact time and place uh leading
up or after january 6th right these are
things that the january 6 committee and
their investigators have done a very
good job at and if you've watched the
hearings like we have and the thousands
of other people that we do with the
minus touch network thank you guys
uh you will see this in real time they
are presenting the case to show you how
they knew what they were doing they
planned what they were doing they went
the legal way and then once the legal
weight [ __ ] dropped out below them
they went in a legal way right they
tried to do this illegally and that is
what we are discussing right now this
this um
this idiotic attempt to throw a coup by
trump and the rest of that party and
we're going to see this testimony on
thursday we're going to see the tick
tock of it and we're going to see his i
think we're going to find out we're
going to have evidence of his intent now
i'm going to bring he might block me
after this i don't know we follow each
other i like go ahead great the last
point i want to make on is the fact that
they are doing the jan6 committee
has has diligently categorized and done
all of the work for them they have the
evidence ready to go they have the
depositions
coded
and so now when the doj says hey we want
that stuff we want those depositions
everything is ready to go it's not like
they're starting from scratch and saying
all right here are tons of files in the
back of this u-haul
go at it they're coming to them and
saying all right this is where it is
this is who said it this is how they
said it this is what they were talking
about this is you know the time the
place what have you everything is ready
to go to get i mean they're basically
handing them the case to say
here are the here are the players in the
game and here's all their strengths and
weaknesses and what they said right so
when the doj takes it they don't have to
start from scratch they're ready to go
so i have don winslow's um
profile on twitter pull up here and he
might block me through this i know and
really first off i want to say don you
are welcome to come on the show anytime
you want uh honestly you can come on
we'll hash this out on live air i don't
give a [ __ ] i i could care less and and
don is a good ally he puts out great
videos he's a great author he's a very
well-known author he's a he's an
international best-selling author
and he he is a good resistor but in this
form and fashion he is actually
promoting authoritarianism and i don't
like that i don't like that and i'm
gonna call it out when i can
and i think people freaking out about
merrick garland is misaimed your
freakout should be aimed towards the
republicans right not towards a
democratic administration where the the
attorney general is trying to do right
by democracy and trying to do right by
justice justice will be served it's
gonna take a bit it's gonna take a bit
jesus christ steve bannon is just now
having his trial for contempt of
congress yeah just now just now and
that's an easy slam dunk
this whole obstructing uh official
proceeding and possible other charges
like witness tampering and stuff of
crimes that have just happened in the
past weeks with trump that is going to
take a while and to get to to prosecute
to indict to get to a grand jury it's
going to take time to sense that case up
now
obviously
don has a huge following and again i
like don i think some of the videos he
produced in 2020 actually helped move
the needle right i really do but his
freakout last night was a little
ridiculous let me know it was it was an
alarmist approach to something i think
that was misinterpreted as this is
really bad right and
at the end of the day what's going on
here is i would almost equate it to the
people that say don't vote right even if
you live in california like myself and
you say yeah whatever it doesn't matter
if i vote or not it does matter because
what you say
in the influence that you have
on on online on tick tock or instagram
or you know on youtube or whatever it
might be your influence has a ripple
effect so if you're going to say oh [ __ ]
the sky is falling
and now this bars
this uh
this bill bar policy from 2020 is now
reinstated
or reenacted in this brief that went out
from garland it means that this is you
know the shit's hitting the fan that
doesn't mean that right if you say that
and you say things like don't vote right
even you know and to address anyone who
says like oh tyt didn't say don't vote
like yeah they do yeah they do they yeah
they what they what they said you know
because somebody tried to clarify it uh
yesterday
i saw that it was like oh tyt saying
they live if you live in california you
can vote how you want doesn't really
matter but again
what you say
has
consequences right what you say will
have a ripple effect to the audience
that follows and listens to you so by
saying don't vote or oh [ __ ] mayor
garland isn't going to indict it has a
ripple effect where people are going to
freak out and then have the approach of
well why does it matter if they're not
going to do anything if the vote doesn't
matter here then why would i partake in
democracy and that is when democracy
fails well because what they want what
the fascists want is when the democracy
falls they can say we didn't have a
democracy anyways and if people really
believe that they're like what's the big
deal who gives a [ __ ] we do have a
democracy and that is the point here
i go back to the bernier bus movement
that might have been some kind of heroic
[ __ ] movement in in in um to to get
the policy to move to the left during
what would have been the hillary clinton
um
administration but look the bust wasn't
in 2016. the bust is right now
your your political rhetoric and
anti-democracy rhetoric because that's
what bernie or bust was is we don't we
didn't get our way in the vote so we're
just going to do whatever we can no
matter what to get our way well even if
it's a defeatist ultimate that's right
is what it is right it's either i get
what i want or i walk away completely
and i let the [ __ ] burn behind me and
not in a good way right and that's not
democracy so here here in this in this
particular tweet and i'm not going to
show all of them but this is a good
freak out tweet here he's freaking out
about merrick garland being bill barr
but the point is that don winslow wants
wants merrick garland to be bill barr so
i can't figure out what the [ __ ] he's
talking about either he wants him to be
an authoritarian like bill barr or he
doesn't i can't figure out what don
wants he says in this tweet merrick
garland could have reverted back to the
doj policy that existed prior to bar
which is in that [ __ ] memo by the way
he could have made his own changes as
barr did in february 2020 which don
winslow was against he was against the
attorney general of the united states it
doesn't i don't give a [ __ ] who it was
rather it was merrick garland or bill
barr to make changes to that policy he
was against it now he's for it since
it's merrick garland doing it right
now the bottom of the tweet says of the
three choices he had garland chose to
reaffirm and extend barr's bad 2020
policy
created to protect trump through 22 and
24. that is not [ __ ] true that's not
true at all bill barr was trying to
prevent any kind of investigation into
the president united states at the time
donald trump is not the president
he is not he is not the president he is
not the president that is not a thing
that donald trump is so
when you're reading don winslow's tweets
because i follow don i like don i like
the videos that he made in 2020 i
actually think don winslow's in his
brilliance in video making pulled
pulled joe biden over the line help do
that
so don my call to you my call to action
to you
is to stop being stop promoting
authoritarianism stop wanting merit
garland 2b billbar stop it stop
trust merrick garden there is nothing in
merrick garland's past nothing that
would that would that would
instigate any kind of freak out that
merrick garland is not going to do the
right thing by the attorney general's
office
now there is a ton of [ __ ] in in jeff
sessions past a ton of [ __ ] and bill
barr's past a ton of [ __ ] in these
fascists past that would give you the
inclination that oh my god they should
not be trusted with the attorney
general's office but merrick garland is
not that way so stop with the freak out
stop because you haven't felt your
satisfaction because i think that's one
thing here is that don has staked his
claim
that trump is not going to be indicted
and he hopes that trump won't be
indicted which i can't even understand
that i don't even i can't wrap my head
around this so don you know i'm telling
you come on the show i'll i will hash it
out in person if you want but also i
mean like the last that i saw from don
which was maybe a month ago or two i i
have no sense of what time is anymore
like many people but i remember don
saying that he was no longer or like
rather not no longer but what he was
going to be doing is he was going to be
funding
uh
people to produce content yeah he's
going to retire from from writing books
from writing to do that and i think that
is an incredible thing to do right now
that is something we really need
but the approach that this we are taking
this defeatist ultimatum like oh well he
either indicts trump or he doesn't and
it looks like he's not gonna and it
looks like he gave him a loophole that's
not what it is it's not saying at all
that you can't indict trump
it again
merrick garland added 131
prosecutors to the investigation that i
think was like 30 something million or
20
20 24 million dollars and or 30 34.1
million dollars to hire additional
lawyers for the january six prosecutions
it is not like they're just like whoop
you guys enter the capitol it's all good
you guys plan you know the capital
insurrection it's all good that's not
what's happening we've talked about it
before on the show
you need to be
you can't just [ __ ] guns blazing jump
through the
the courtroom door and say this man is
going to trial and he's guilty like if
you don't actually have the case
prepared if you [ __ ] up along the way if
you went way worse and detailed you can
[ __ ] it up which means up the case gets
overturned and they don't get to
prosecute them again unless there is
some new point of evidence that they can
use as a reference but if they go in
and they jump start the race
they mess up they cause a foul they are
not able to go back right and so this is
just i mean you have to remember that
merrick garland this is not his first
rodeo okay you know he had oklahoma
oklahoma city bombing uh the atlanta
olympics bombing like this is someone
who has
the experience and has the history of
dealing with high-profile domestic
terrorist racks
like this is something that is again
it's not his first rodeo this is not him
just like throwing [ __ ] to the wind and
seeing which way it goes he's not going
to go all of a sudden prematurely and
say we're going to indict trump
and have nothing there right again the
january 6th is
preparing all of the evidence they are
communicating it might not be having a
happening as fast as you want
but it is happening and just be thankful
that it is happening
because if they they didn't really care
about it and they weren't doing the the
proper preparation for it then it would
never happen because they would just
[ __ ] up well you know i think that's
what he's saying in the memo too and i
don't think it's actually what he's
trying to say to the public but he's
trying to tell his united states
attorneys in these districts because
those are the people that actually can
mean the grand juries they're the ones
that bring the indictments mayor garland
doesn't actually bring the indictments
he's the attorney general he's the he's
the head of the entire department of
justice he's over the fbi he has a lot
of stuff to worry about than a single
indictment inside of a district
regardless of how high profile it is now
the the point of that that i'm trying to
make is that i think he's trying to tell
his prosecutors hey
you know be careful about these about
these elections don't bring indictments
with the pressure from people like you
know don
that you have to bring an indictment
before an election because it our
elections will be bust if we don't you
can't bring an indictment like that and
the reason why is because someone like
trump
will absolutely exploit that if he if he
can and he will he will and they know
that they know that merrick garden knows
that these [ __ ] chuckleheads are
going to exploit any kind of excuse they
can for a defense jesus christ steve
bannon got turned down again this
morning for trying to [ __ ] extend his
trial and he's trying to get his trial
extended past the midterm i know that's
what he's trying to do because he knows
he's going to go to prison he knows he's
going to be locked up during the midterm
and he's not going to be able to to yell
and scream and push his propaganda his
fascist propaganda into a microphone and
it's gonna hurt the midterms he knows
that bannon knows that
trump knows that at this point that's
why they're trying everything they can
do any kind of [ __ ] angle that they
can take to get out of this mess that
they put themselves in that's speaking
and put themselves in a mess here's
another former trump white house aide
garrett zigler
tied to the unhinged december 2020 uh
oval office meeting talks
with house january 6 committee this
guy's going to go in to be deposed now
this is the one who actually let them in
the door and by them i mean sydney
powell mike flynn rudy giuliani they
just showed up out of nowhere and we saw
it in the actual deposition that the
january 6 played of sydney power she's
sipping the diet dr pepper she's like
yeah [ __ ] we didn't know what she did i
think she kind of she chugged it she
finished that [ __ ] put it down and
then laughed off this idea that
you know
it's but the person that let him in the
white house the person that led him in
the white house is now going to be
deposed by the january 6th select
committee so that think and and all that
information is what the department of
justice is going to receive and yes it's
going to take some time for the
department of justice to
to dive into this mountain of evidence
against trump and his allies rather it
be his legal team rather be the actual
enforcers on the ground with the oath
keepers and the proud boys it's gonna
take time to build these cases and to
actually make the case for charges for
indictments to make sure that they stick
because that is the last thing that the
department of justice wants to do and
the last thing i think that americans
want
is that if they indict trump that he
skates on it i think that would be much
worse than him even not being prosecuted
in my view i mean what would happen yeah
what would happen if if they tried to go
forward and they're like well nope this
got thrown out because you guys didn't
do this right right and then everyone's
like oh how could you [ __ ] this up
and it's like okay hold on wait wait
wait wait you either want them to do you
either think they're going to do it or
not going to do it if you think they're
going to do it then let give them give
them the patience or give them the space
to do what they're doing again
all of the moves that they've been
making have clearly been indicative of
the fact that they are pursuing this
right
you have to go the outer circle and you
make your way in you can't just
immediately unless unless trump is like
yep i plan the coup i did it and here's
all the evidence right
you're going from the outside in
right eastman clark all the people who
were like yeah
he told us to go on the building we had
connections with the oath keepers the
proud boys roger stone like all of these
things you go from the outside in it's
exactly the same approach that you would
take if you were going against i don't
know the mob
so like
that's the approach but people want
immediate right we live in a world that
is
instant gratification right and i i
agree like i would very much want to see
the perp walk of trump in complete
orange you know not just his face
but complete orange going to prison well
here's my ears might happen we have to
wait a little bit
yeah here's my prediction
because i i was right on this guy here i
was right on this guy oh whoa that is
that is very white that is very white
whoosh
elon won the color of the year by the
way i was right on this guy the nips on
this guy by the way um i was right on
this guy about not buying uh twitter
now i'm making a prediction here yes
trump will be indicted now i don't know
who will come first and what i mean by
that is rather we will see the
indictment from the state of georgia
rather we will see the indictment in the
federal district of dc rather we will
see it in the federal district of new
york um or in florida or any other state
that this guy has committed crimes right
i think that donald trump will be
indicted
i don't know if he'll get convicted i
hope so now my my real question the
question that i have the most that i
question myself and trying to figure
this out
is i
i question how is a federal judge going
to incarcerate a former president that
is the question that i continue to ask
myself because i think that is one of
the most difficult things that we'll
deal with right the fact that he
committed crime it's obvious that he
committed crime right
rather whether the department of justice
brings charges or not you know that
might be an obvious thing the the actual
trial itself might be an obvious thing
but i think the actual question we have
to ask ourselves in this country is is
will a federal because a federal judge
gets to decide right that that that
particular point and i mean whoever gets
that case oh [ __ ] that [ __ ] that [ __ ]
right because you're because you're
damned to be doing damn david right
exactly you've got yeah you'll have hate
on either side you didn't go hard enough
you went too lenient oh he should have
been free should have been free like
that is the one situation in which
you're like
we're gonna come into some you know
maybe rough waters right right on how
you decide because here's the thing
we've never done that before no we have
not done that that is a rubicon we have
not crossed that whether you want to
argue it'll make this country look weak
or it'll make it look strong
yet to be determined because people will
interpret however they want they'll say
oh you're going over your own that is a
weak weak thing that you would do right
oh you didn't go after your own clearly
you allow for anything to happen which
means now you've created a precedent and
now anyone can do whatever they want and
trying to push that envelope further
further further into fascism well and
that's really the issue that we have
with electing someone like trump is
because we don't want to cross these
rubicons these are rubicons we don't
want to cross but he has forced us to
cross these things and to
find out what these things are it would
have been much better in our country
if in december when the college
um that they that the oath keepers were
searching for are the proud boys who was
searching for the electoral college you
remember the march in dc they were
searching for the college the electoral
count they didn't understand that the
college is in the states they were
actually trying to find the universe
anyways anyways in december when they
actually when the state certified the
votes if donald trump when bill barr
said hey and mitch mcconnell came to the
floor and said hey it's over it's done
you're [ __ ] it doesn't matter what
happens here it's over
if he would have just come out and
conceded at that moment
packed his [ __ ]
and left
willingly with a concession he could run
in 2024. and we wouldn't even be having
this conversation we would not be having
this conversation but we are because he
can't help himself he can't stop criming
jesus christ there is evidence just out
in the open just in the last week that
the guy has been committing federal
crimes just in the last two months
during the hearings
speaking of crimes and speaking of what
you can do to change our democracy
go vote like that's the whole thing
there's key races like this race in
georgia
this race in georgia is super important
with hershel walker
to keep that seat for warnock to keep
that seat is going to be super important
for our democracy that's what's going to
make sure we don't cross other rubicons
here
that is the most important thing is yes
it is important for us to prosecute
trump and for us to know the truth in
this country but us
for us not to continue to do this this
crazy nonsense we're elect these crazy
people have you seen this video where
he's talking about how he was going to
murder someone is this the one where he
talks about the fbi
well yes but it's it the fbi is the
worst the least of the worries i don't
know
i think this is
i may have seen this video this is from
this is not recent this is from a while
ago that's right this is he claims to be
in the fbi didn't but listen to what
he's talking about he's gonna he says
he's gonna murder someone with a gun
watch i work for the poor law
enforcement i didn't know that either
did you i spent time at quantico
education now you got trainers that's a
lot you all know i was agent i sure
should tell y'all that y'all don't care
but anyway yeah i've been in law
enforcement so i grabbed my gun i said i
will kill him
personal walking one heist control i'm
gonna kill him i got in what one of my
many i took off in 183
and i just hear that he said he was
going to kill someone with a gun
look look keep keep listening i remember
divorcing hurts of people and
disrespecting you all the time
people are always doing stuff to you
you've never done nothing to know he's
the victim and all of a sudden this
other voice is hurting your parents and
raise your hand
nobody did yesterday i thought i was
losing my mind
as i got closer and closer to where i
was going to meet this guy
i started to pray i said lord uh
i need some help right now so now he
invokes god you know this guy's always
gonna vote
as he's gonna go murder someone
to murder this person right right now
jesus christ this guy
i said i need you to help me i said it
i'm about to do something stupid right
now i need you to help me right now
i remember getting to this where i was
going to meet a man i got out of my car
and i put my hand on my gun and it's all
walking to this truck he's going to
murder this person why would he what
he's describing
why why is the hand on the gun right why
are we already like again i mean this is
an issue with police in terms of law
enforcement of like already having like
the assumption that something's going to
go wrong
i don't know maybe maybe not put the
hands
this is absolutely nuts that there's
people considering voting for this guy
who said he went to murder someone if i
remember correctly
this video he's talking to a bunch of
younger people
i don't know back and i almost want to
say because there's a whole thing about
how him not being able to read and him
playing football and [ __ ] like that
and i think he's talking to a group of
like kids or teenagers or something
something some young group of people
now he's got a cassius clay shirt on
which some might might make bones about
that um you know in today's age
where
muhammad ali changed his name from
cassius clay right i don't know if he's
trying to you know
send signals there i have no idea but
but here let's listen to the end of this
where he's going to murder this guy
before i could see the guy i saw the
sign on the back of his truck that said
hunk if you love jesus oh [ __ ] and
that's what calmed me down oh my god
well that is what thanks
thank goodness thank goodness that that
person had the word jesus on the back of
his truck
he or our herschel walker would have had
just had to murder him right like you
you think jesus christ you think of this
and it's like oh man i saw this person
and they were killed like in the example
he's like i saw this person they were
murdering someone but i saw
on his bracelet it said wwjd
and i said
you keep doing your thing man i can't
kill this person you're right exactly
like that's the type of logic that they
have is like i saw a sign from jesus it
was a bracelet it was a bumper sticker
it was a license plate it was somebody
driving by and they were singing some
hymn or psalm out of their car
and i took it as a sign i saw you know i
saw my grilled cheeses and it looked
like you know it's like real cheese
that's great well here's the thing
it bores me that messaging in georgia
should be this
you can vote for warnock who work for
you or you can vote for herschel walker
who wants to murder people right it's
pretty simple what the [ __ ] is going on
how how in the [ __ ] can't we just
message and get this out understand look
yes do we want trump prosecuted and for
january 6 and all the january sixers and
the insurrectionists and the traders
prosecuted yes then it's going to happen
it's going to take a while but protect
our democracy in the meantime protect
our democracy don't burn or bust this
thing don't don't give up now now's the
time to make sure that we have people in
place that are going to protect our
democracy and not
take it down another [ __ ] wild path
like i don't know murdering someone we
have some breaking news here now let's
go to breaking news
carol linning has a uh
article out right now it's talking about
purge have you read part of this article
about the national archives yeah secret
service reading a little bit right now
basically saying that there is uh today
was the deadline tuesday was the
deadline where they were supposed to
hand over the secret service tech the
text messages from i believe it was
january 5th and the 6th right is what
they want it's you know it's also very
odd why were those the only days that
were deleted you know and then they say
well this is typical this is how we kind
of purge the phone so we make sure it's
like no no no no that is not exactly
true
so they've determined that there are you
know the secret service have come
forward and determined that there are no
new texts provided to congress that are
relevant to its january 6 investigation
how convenient and that any other texas
agents in exchange around the time of
2021 attack on the capitol were purged
according to senior official briefed on
the matter
also the national archives on tuesday
sought more information on the potential
unauthorized deletion because again this
is not the way that it goes about i
think even mueller she wrote talks about
it because she has experience working
for the government and how
devices are handled she even said you
know
she was able to go back and get uh
uh old access to an uh emails or her
computer i
forget which one or if they were both
connected but she was indicating how
that process works and this isn't
typical this is this is not the way that
it normally goes so this is an
unauthorized deletion especially when
you look at the timeline of when things
were requested and when they're like oh
[ __ ]
and then they're like we don't have it
right because it was requested i think
10 days after january 6th so we're
talking january 16 around that time 2021
and the watchdog group was like hey can
we get those texts
and then the secret service eventually
was like well we don't have those texts
they're no longer there right yeah we
deleted them right they incriminated us
why would we keep those sticks right and
it's the same type this is not you know
the other thing too is
they're um
the presidential twitter it's just an
example the presidential twitter account
is something that is archived right so
the dms that you have going on there are
all archived when it comes to personal
accounts those are not so for trump
there's a ton of these dms that are
missing
or have been deleted
from uh from personal accounts between
ivanka mark meadows and other people
wait wait he was dming on twitter
yes he was committing wait wait wait
wait wait he was i don't know anything i
don't know who wants
twitter but it is potential that he was
because these things are now
[ __ ]
come on man
so that's what you know that's what's
happening right they're throwing they're
throwing around dms and text messages
and deleting this burning papers
flushing them eating them like they're
trying to get rid of them innocent
people
do not eat [ __ ] paper right this
isn't like
uh uh like my weird obsession on [ __ ]
tlc okay
it is not that okay because there's some
weird [ __ ] on there but this is not that
at all right you do not eat papers you
you do not flush papers you do not burn
papers like meadows and others were
doing right cassidy hutchinson being one
of the people that whitney was like
what's going on here like what what's
what's the deal what's what are we what
are we why are we disposing of these
papers right
a president does not take
15 boxes worth of confidential
information which we still are going to
figure out that what happened there
right
that you know innocent people don't
plead the fifth innocent people don't
say oh my my rights are being violated
because you're taking my cell phone dude
if you had nothing to hide you had
nothing to hide then you would just show
it if you had nothing to hide then you
wouldn't play the if you had nothing to
hide then you would not ignore subpoena
and now like some of these people like
uh steve bannon or peter navarro who are
in contempt of congress like these are
people who ignored it because they're
guilty
who went out and publicly they said the
thing out loud and are now denying their
involvement and not willing to
participate in a uh under oath type of
situation gabe you have offended part of
our audience here what did i say the the
420 god says i eat lsd paper
oh okay
come on okay i'm sorry take it
you do not eat
documents that have read the government
that have been printed out either what
if what if they're laced with lsd i mean
it it could be listen to lsd there's a
lot there's a lot of talk right now on
twitter about adderall maybe maybe those
notes had adderall laced into the paper
i don't know how could you tell how
could you do that okay typically when i
and i will say this have done it it is
on small little tabs right i'm not
talking eight and a half by eleven sheet
of paper that you've printed out that
has something on there that's a lot of
lsd of a
this type of thing innocent people don't
just delete stuff or eat stuff or flush
stuff or burn stuff or plead the fifth
or or you know don't uh uh comply with
the subpoena i mean the party of just
comply
doesn't want to comply
that should tell you everything you need
to know about the people that have
planned this coup and continue
to plan this coup right
well i think i think that's right and
and i think
that if you really think about what we
were talking about with merrick garland
here
is
here here we have another situation
where there's going to be more criminal
investigation it's going to take longer
to get to the bottom of it i mean it re
it really is it really does speak to why
you must be patient here but while
you're being patient on waiting to see
what happens with the criminal
indictments don't forget to engage in
your democracy it is
vitally important right just in the
absolute just the craziness that one of
the senate candidates in georgia
is is out there on on the trail or in
front of people talking about how he
tried to murder someone and he didn't
because they had a jesus sticker on
their truck
speaking of murder and delusional
delusional murders have you seen this
clip you have to do this clip on what
was that because as soon as i as soon as
i watched this yeah i was like what was
what what the [ __ ] is she talking about
yeah i might have to do a like i've i've
i've debated trying to do these uh these
like shorter like mini what was that
right oh okay okay so like little little
blurbs well because i'm also trying to
think like oh well [ __ ] because this
clip is like what eight seconds long and
she says no but i mean it has to do with
the supreme court so maybe
uh i'm working to wrap up the one that i
have upcoming yeah for tomorrow great
which is on alex stein
the guy who's sexually harassed the
sexual harasser
i got that one and then there will be a
uh uh speaking of just another one
before the january 6 hearings there will
be uh a recap of the seventh hearing
before we lead into the eighth one
um grumpy cat ask a question here is
that mcginnima yes it's um it's kaylee
mcinning she's
she's the she's the former she's the
former press secretary and the former
liar and for the liar in chief yeah she
would come out and
give all her lies and this clip is only
a few seconds long but listen to what
she claims here who got assassinated
listen
she claims someone got assassinated and
i'm not sure what this means but let's
listen you look at the left they can go
out and say you know nothing about the
kavanaugh assassination yes the press
secretary did the president didn't
what that what assassination did she say
brett gavin has been assassinated is
there something that the q and honors
know that we don't let me let's play it
again i don't know look at the left they
can go out in and say you know nothing
about the kavanaugh assassination yes
they can say nothing about the kavanaugh
assassin what the [ __ ] are they talk
what does she do is she talking about
the guy who was within six miles right
is she thinking is she is it you know i
mean is this like the bone like the the
bowling green massacre like this is the
same type of thing
that was kellyanne conway right right
that was kellyanne conway yeah she was
like oh we did the bowling green
massacre which you know became a
a funny meme
but yeah i don't know if this is like
them they're like oh i wish this
happened but i'm saying the quiet part
out loud or this is you know i don't
know exactly what they're what they're
kind of discussing but there is
something else i just sent you this
breaking news this is also this happened
about this video was shared about 30
minutes ago from
someone who was uh
i think this is from the actual person
who was on the tour okay well uh let's
go to breaking news
i like the bracing news thing yeah this
is this is from the hoover dam right
yeah hoover dam i've been there never
been always wanted to go so so i give
you a good story um we actually went on
9 11 not the not the day 9 11 but on on
september 11th and it was the very day i
think it was 10 years after so it would
have been 2011.
i i believe so i i have to i have to
think about that for a second but it was
the first day that they let the
elevators go back down into the dam when
i visited that day because it had been
so many years after 9 11 they hadn't
allowed but here we see it looks like
there's gonna there's an explosion
um down on the i forget what they call
it um on the dam there
and i'm i'm i'm having a brain fart but
um
they actually there looks like to be an
explosion i don't know let's watch in
this video folks get your video on that
there's just been an incident here my
goodness something's just blown up
something has just blown out
yeah folks get your video on that
there's just been an incident here my
goodness get your video on that what
does he mean by that i guess that's a
tour guide there right yeah it sounds
like that's the tour guide he's like hey
grab your video get that and let's get
the hell out of here is what he's kind
of saying
so it looks like uh they're still trying
to figure out what's going on you know
this was
when how long was this 36 minutes ago
this was posted so you know now hoover
dam is a a very very vital piece of
infrastructure not just uh for water but
for electric as well um and it is
heavily guarded that's why that's why
after 9 11 they weren't allowing people
to go down inside the dam to tour it
right that's why that day that we went
it just so happened it was on september
11th that we would go years later after
the 9 11 attacks but we went that day
and that's when the first day that they
actually allowed people down and we
didn't plan it that way just it just
happened to be yeah um but you know they
were very um
very very very
adamant about security at that time now
it's been years ago that this happened
but um
yeah something's happening at the the
hoover dam
um with an explosion so and keep an eye
on that story
there were some other um things trending
today other than the garland thing which
i thought was
uh and it looks like hoover dam is now
trending too if you go to the trent the
tweety tweets and the trendy trends so
keep up on that story you guys know that
that's that's one thing i want to bring
up that you know we don't just surf the
tweety tweets and trendy trends because
it sounds funny or um because this is
actually a good way to keep up on what
is trending the news that is trending um
and here you see hoover dam trending uh
you also garland
uh jim harbaugh is trending but garland
is also trending
because it's an important topic that
people are talking about but here's
another one that i think people should
point out and what makes our democrats
and republicans are exactly the same
they're exactly the same there's no
different [ __ ] here's another story
that proves that republicans are
absolutely pieces of [ __ ] [ __ ] that
democrats are not and that their aim for
democracy is a hell of a lot different
than than republicans republicans want
fascism 18 republicans including
marjorie taylor green matt gatz and
lauren bobert and i think tom massey is
even on that [ __ ] list yeah yeah yeah
yeah uh all more breaking news yeah more
geez man this this morning is
but as you're giving me that link they
voted against sweden and finland joining
nato right our western allies in in in
the in the um in the aim of democracy
and uh to stave off authoritarian states
like russia and vladimir putin what's
this link you got here for me here
this is uh multiple members of congress
getting arrested uh by capitol police
for blocking traffic outside the supreme
court
for an abortions right demonstration so
oh okay so these are setting members of
congress and they're there for um a pro
pro women's pro abortion rights yeah pro
bodily autonomy um okay let's see let me
pull this up here uh looks like andrew's
got a report here with a video um
and it's it's reporting multiple members
of congress including aoc
is arrested
um hey hey alex stein if you want to see
what uh an
actual
tough protest looks like this is what it
looks like dumb [ __ ] not yelling and cat
calls it someone in sexual harassing
someone and then sexually it was a
compliment it was a compliment
[ __ ] that guy piece of [ __ ]
um here but let's watch the video here
of aoc being arrested for protesting
good for aoc
that's good trouble right there
and that's what we need more of um you
know i'm not always in support of
everything aoc says or does right um you
know i'm not necessarily in agreeance
with her but i definitely
definitely uh think that aoc is doing
the good american thing right here by
getting arrested for people's rights
right and and especially fascists taking
away people's rights but if you go sorry
i didn't mean to cut you off earlier but
kind of going back just kind of lightly
on this is the the voting against
finland and sweden like what is the
justification here right
what is the justification for them not
to join
there is no reason the reason why is
because it would it would weaken it
would re it would weaken their vladdy
daddy is what is the right why but it's
but what i want to know is like i mean i
know that obviously
say no uh would have that effect but i
want to know what and this might take
more time but to figure out what they're
saying what their excuses to say no you
guys can't come in like why would you
not well let's go see here's the great
part about being on twitter we can just
go right in here and see if there's a
video of it let's see if there's any
video of them explaining hey look
there's us explaining
ew hey i i would imagine though it has
something to do with putting cheeto dust
knee pads on or
you know um capitulating to putin they
love putin matt gantz marjorie taylor
green
someone's gotta pay them you know i'm
trying they need to secure that paycheck
once they get booted outside of congress
i doubt there's gonna be a video of
these [ __ ] chuckleheads getting in
front of microphone trying to explain
why they wanna hold up and support
authoritarian states around the united
states i would imagine that matt gatz
and marjorie taylor green are going to
leave it for their shitty podcast i
would say so i don't think we're going
to find anything right now
there's something on the ohio supreme
court here that is trending
tosses out gop drawn congressional map
uh uh-oh uh so the ohio supreme court is
not going to play ball with the
a gop
map for 2024 and that's pretty important
and not as important in this year but is
important oh no andy noah's trending why
is this guy trending i saw that oh jesus
oh jesus
andy no you guys
know he's the guy who who who uh does uh
antifa cosplay and films it as if it's
real yeah except he's always hanging out
with the proud boys he took a rubber rod
aka the dildo to the face he also took a
cement shake now here's the thing i
don't know if someone actually threw the
dildo at his face it could have been
just like what happened with the cement
milkshake which turned out to be fake
and that he had done it to himself but
the right we had someone do it
and yeah the right wing had ted cruz
they doubled down on him and was like oh
yeah andy noah is a victim of blm antifa
and the left wing uh uh you know army or
whatever and then it turns out that andy
noe was actually lying
and not
uh
and not was attacked right and here's
chad loader they they have a tweet here
just under an hour ago maybe this will
explain it andy knows what andy know was
exposed yesterday in court of having
uh corrabora
collaborated with right-wing extremists
in their violent 2019 attack with now
patrons on the cider riot pub in
response no has decided to engage in the
blatant witness intimidation scheme
against one of the prosecutors witnesses
that sounds like
yeah it sounds like uh andy noah could
be in some trouble here so thanks chad
for your for your tweet maybe that
giving us some insight um obviously
when these people do you know play
stupid games they win stupid prizes
especially when you start [ __ ] with
the elections and you start [ __ ] with
government you start [ __ ] the
politics you know i've said it time and
time and time again gabe we're at the
intersection of wrestlemania in real
life and these people think it's some
kind of show right it's like
entertainment for them oh yeah it's
entertainment but what they don't
understand is these choices that you
make inside of politics and inside of
government they actually have real world
of real world effect where where when
you like something like sports or or
wrestling or maybe a tv show a reality
tv show where you're really excited
about it right that doesn't really have
a real world effect when you're arguing
with someone about you know
a reality tv show on on on the tube
right but when you're when you're making
government and you're making our
democracy the reality tv show that
you're banging up it really does have
real world effects and the problem is
sometimes
sometimes it might just be illegal i
think that might just be um i i want to
get your take on this story because
we only got a few minutes left um a
texas blogger
um
uh
paid by democratic representative
gonzalez campaign
have you seen this explain explain i i'm
not sure what this i no no no i don't
know this story
uh okay i know of her
uh which she's part of the gop right
flores yes
but but apparently this blogger has um
been paid by her uh a representative a
democratic representative gonzalez's
campaign to attack
uh flores um
yeah i don't i'm here's the thing you
know it kind of it it fall i believe
this is something that also falls in
line with what happened with aoc right
you know it's not just poking good fun
at someone it's not just i'm trolling
them no you're being racist and you're
being sexist and if you're gonna you
know
if this is true and this person this
democratic candidate is paying a blogger
to attack
myra flores like
whatever her political plenty of things
to attack her yeah
but if you're going to go miss frijoles
and or cotton pick and lie or like i
don't know what what is what is what
does that mean what does that mean
cotton pick and liar i'm assuming no no
no
miss oh frijoles yes if they're making
up they're making a pun of frijoles the
food a hispanic dish right that is uh
that is a play off her name flores ryra
flores right as miss frijoles i don't
know if there's some background on like
if there actually says something but it
says on the blog which was called flores
miss frijoles 21 times since then and
has not publicized any gonzalez ads so
yeah like it's just
and it's being denounced by democrats
but i was i i was unaware with like what
the inner workings of this work was no
it's just like a word was derogatory i
just yeah i didn't know it is it is one
that i would say is not i would say is
derogatory and i would say is a punch at
her
for her hispanic name and hispanic food
and trying to belittle her that way i
can guarantee there are tons of things
that you can go after a candidate for
but trying to do something like that
like i said is the same approach that
you find alex stein going going after
aoc for right we're having a big booty
or something which i i i want to i want
to clarify it's a hot tamale oh
picante spice by spice like that's the
type of [ __ ] that he was saying right
it's the same thing here if you're
trying to make fun of someone in that
way there are many other ways you can go
after policy you can have the things
that they said but if you're going after
a name like that i think it's dumb and i
think it's right well here's here's what
i'll say is because uh on on the aoc
thing because that was very viral right
a lot of people saw that video of that
[ __ ] chucklehead that that piece of
[ __ ] uh sexually harassing aoc aoc is a
beautiful woman and she does she's
gorgeous she has a great body she's very
beautiful woman she's a very beautiful
woman she's a very sexy woman i believe
and i think there's a thousand different
ways a thousand different ways that alex
stein could point out that that aoc is a
very attractive woman even though he
disagrees with her there's a thousand
different ways but he chose the one way
the one way that he could to sexually
harass her and to try to and to try to
let her know that he was sexually
harassing her right that was the
intention so
regardless of of what he believes about
her or what the joke is or if she's
really gorgeous or she's not or she she
has a hot ass or whatever you want to
say there's a thousand different ways
for a person to express that aoc is a
beautiful woman even right in front of
her face
even right in front of her face there's
a way to express that you think she's a
very attractive woman but you disagree
with her and because he called her a
baby killer and all this [ __ ] and then
he and then he sexually harassed her and
it went on and on and on and i look
forward to your what was that because
i've gotten i've gotten some research
that you've done on stein himself that i
don't think a lot of people have dove
into so i'm really there's a lot out
there and i only have so much time right
now available so i'm really i'm really
looking forward to that hopefully uh
tomorrow
we can
we'll play it on the show have it ready
we'll play it on the show how does that
sound and then we'll get it over on the
other
hand
i saw someone say like aren't they both
hispanic yes both representatives that
are running right right gonzalez
gonzalez the only higher right yeah yeah
right the the thing here though is who
is the blogger right it could be you
know if it was gonzales saying it
doesn't and still it's like it could be
done better but it's you know one
within within the same culture right
however
who is the blogger right i don't know
who the blogger is but still it's like
again regardless it's
not clever
in the sense of like what does it do
to actually identify and address the
policies or the things that they're
running out what is the platform how
does changing the name it's no better
than trump calling somebody whatever you
know well like it doesn't it doesn't add
anything really to say like oh if i were
to say like oh they're mis
uh
i don't know like
something that would be against their
policy right something i guess the
platform they that they stand on sure
well flores has a lot of really horrible
policies yeah yeah on on on migrants on
immigration on on on uh people coming to
this country and what that policy is
there's plenty of ways to attack her on
that policy in particular and other
policies the like without you know
making up some kind of you know right
what seems like a racist nickname um
and i guess we have to track down who
the actual blogger is well it looks like
it's it's a texas blogger it's called
the mchale report
um
is
but a lot of democrats are denouncing
this stuff yeah yeah again like there
are many other ways many effective ways
many ways that are not trying to make a
racist play on someone's name or making
them the butt of the joke in that way
again there is probably something
they've said and probably something they
believe in and the platform they stand
on you could easily attack those things
well the other thing too
the other thing too is you give flores
you give flores a narrative that you
don't want her to have in the first
place by doing this so i i'm with you on
this and speaking speaking of attacks
and great attacks and how to do attacks
what you should do is you should go see
some of the attacks that jon fetterman
is absolutely filing on top and make
embarrassing him
so badly in pennsylvania the that he's
gonna tuck his tail and run back to new
jersey i gotta say whoever is in charge
of the marketing campaign for fetterman
outstanding
they are using
in
uh inexpensive ways right to have the
most effective outcomes right it's
fantastic
the amount of ratio ratioing that is
happening to
just on twitter alone just like it's
insane
wow it is insane it sucks to suck gabe
it sucks to suck and everyone out there
remember you have to do your due
diligence no matter what garland does no
matter what the january 6 select
community does you have to do your due
diligence you have to participate in
your democracy because you are the thing
that are going to make sure that we
don't slide down further
into this crazy hole of fascism and and
those races the key races are some of
those senate races that we're talking
about right here the one in ohio the one
in pennsylvania the one in georgia hell
the one in missouri that's coming up the
one in arizona be paying attention to
those races
and be doing the thing that you need to
do which is engage in your democracy and
staying strategically outraged do that
by coming here every single weekday
monday through friday
uh
noon eastern 11 central nine pacific on
youtube twitter twitch and simulcasting
from the midas touch facebook page until
tomorrow surf's up [ __ ]
you've been listening to the tony
michaels podcast
in your face commentary of current
events and political news no rules no
boundaries i think we've made that
perfectly clear we hope you enjoyed the
show and we'll be back soon in the
meantime follow tony on social media at
the tony michaels and until next time
raise a fist and repeat after me
[ __ ] them
[Music]
murphy's mealborn had asked